Film Courage: What is sci-fi and what does
it mean to the two of you?
Marc Scott Zicree: Wow!
That’s an interesting question.
That is a big question.
Well…should I take it Elaine because I’m
the science fiction geek [laughs].
Well science fiction [sighs] is a wonderful
playground because it allows us to comment
on our world in a way that makes it much more
universal.
For instance, when Rod Serling came up with
TWILIGHT ZONE he was censored by the networks
and sponsors by saying anything he wanted
to say about politics or race or social issues
of the day.
So he created TWILIGHT ZONE so he could comment
on those things without the censors removing
it and as a result those TWILIGHT ZONE episodes
are as timely now in the Trump era as they
ever were when he was writing when Eisenhower
or Kennedy was president.
So I love the fact that science fiction allows
me to reach an audience of people around the
world and the work lasts decades and actually
centuries ultimately.
Elaine Zicree: And it also seems to inspire
people because there are so many things that
were jumped off from things like Star Trek,
where geek kids grew up to be geek scientists
and they actually jumped in and they made
it real, so it really is inspirational.
One thing I really like about science fiction
is it’s the same thing with stories in small
towns or westerns.
It’s where a lot of the complexities of
modern life is stripped away and we can really
focus on moral and emotional issues in a much
clearer way.
Marc Scott Zicree: Yes…And also if you kill
a character you can bring them back because
you can clone them or whatever.
Elaine Zicree: I’m particularly good at
that.
Marc Scott Zicree: …Have their head in a
tank with nutrients or whatever.
It’s really fun.
Film Courage: Do you remember when the two
of you were exposed to the first sci-fi story
and where you were, how old you were? Marc
Scott Zicree: Well between the two of us I’m
the real science fiction geek.
I mean Elaine was reading Dostoevsky when
she was a kid and Tolstoy…
Elaine Zicree: But I wanted a robot!
Marc Scott Zicree: You wanted a robot toy,
exactly.
But my first experience with science fiction
when I was a kid I was reading comic books
from as early as I can remember.
My first favorite book was Farmer in the Sky
by Robert A. Heinlein… when I was age 7.
I just grew up in the genres of TWILIGHT,
STAR TREK, THE OUTER LIMITS.
Those were TV shows that made me want to be
a writer.
And as soon as I was a teenager I ended up
going to science fiction conventions meeting
those writers, the writers that had written
for those shows, Harlan Ellison, D.C.
Fontana, David Gerrold, Theodore Sturgeon,
Richard Matheson, George Clayton Johnson,
Ray Bradbury… and many of them became friends
and mentors.
So I definitely knew where home was for me.
Elaine Zicree: And I was more brought up on
some of the social issues of some of the older
writers like 1984 [author George Orwell] and
H.G. Wells where they were exploring social
issues.
So rather than the newer writers, I knew the
older ones.
My parents leaned strongly to the left and
so did I and we found their ability to explore
things, where people would not put up walls
because it was in the future, allowed them
a much greater freedom to reach into people’s
thought processes and feelings without defensiveness.
Marc Scott Zicree: That’s sort of the sum
of it.
When I was a kid I was given a Christmas present
of a trip to the STAR TREK set, so I was there
for the last episode of the original STAR
TREK ever shot, Turnabout Intruder.
So I got to sit in the captain’s chair and
stand on the transporter.
I remember looking up and seeing there was
just a lightbulb screwed into the transporter
above my head and I thought “Huh?
Well, gee…”
I remember thinking how small the engineering
on the STAR TREK set was a forced perspective
and I was thinking “Gee, this is a lot smaller
than it looks on television.”
And it was just an amazing day, a wonderful,
wonderful day.
The best Christmas present ever.
Question for the Viewers: What does Sci-Fi
mean to you?